while most conservative
and liberal pundits
are at each other's throats
concerning guns,
Fox News host Gretchen Carlson
kind of went off script.
There's no doubt
that Omar Mateen
was able to kill so many people
because he was firing an AR-15,
a weapon easier to buy
in the state of Florida
than buying a handgun.
I'm also with the majority today
taking a stand.
Can't we hold true the sanctity
of the Second Amendment
while still having common sense?
By the way, Fox News employees,
swing by
Buffalo Wild Wings tonight
for Gretchen Carlson's
farewell party.
(laughter, shouts, whooping)
I'm telling you, there's
no way Fox is keeping her
-after that, man.
-(laughter)
Good for you, Gretchen.
Good for you.
And to help Gretchen...
you know, to help Gretchen
land a new job, we got her
the MSNBC starter pact.
-(laughter)
-So, here we go.
-(audience whooping)
-There we go. Very nice.
-(applause)
-It's all here.
Uh, the short androgynous
brunette wig,
black glasses,
and a Ta-Nehisi Coates book.
-Uh... let's see how she'll look
-(laughter)
for her MSNBC job interview.
Oh! Nice.
Perfect! I like it!
I like it a lot.
(laughing):
Very good.
Everyone should have
one of those, I think.
They really should.
(chuckles)
Meanwhile, senate Democrats
are tired
of just talking about guns.
They want action.
NEWSMAN: Led by Connecticut
senator, Chris Murphy,
Democrats commandeering
the senate floor,
trying to force a vote
to toughen up gun laws.
And so I'm gonna remain
on this floor
until we get some signal,
some sign...
that we can come together...
I tried that line
on Halle Berry.
(laughter)
Still waiting!
So the Democrats are fighting
for two amendments, right?
Expanding background checks
and preventing
people on the no-fly list
from being able to buy guns.
Now, these are no-brainers,
especially the no-fly list one.
In fact, it's such a no-brainer
that even someone
with barely a brain agrees.
NEWSMAN: Trump signaling
an openness to new restrictions
that would ban people
on the terrorist watch list
or the no-fly list
from buying guns.
Yes, guys,
Trump makes a good point.
But calm down--
you can hit a piano with a bat
and still get a couple
of notes, all right?
-(laughter)
-Bam!
Doesn't make you Rachmaninoff.
It does not, all right?
And, by the way,
even the Benghazi Kid agrees.
If you are too dangerous
to get on a plane,
you are too dangerous
to buy a gun.
Well, I don't know,
I don't know.
'Cause under that logic,
then no mother (bleep) snakes
can buy
any mother (bleep) guns...
(laughter, whooping)
...'cause they are not allowed
on any mother (bleep) plane.
Is that your vision
of America, Hillary?
Eh!
All right,
so both sides agree, right?
But, you know,
here's the thing, guys,
here's the thing-- when
both sides agree so quickly
after being so far apart
on everything,
that's when I generally
get worried, okay?
So let's really
think this through.
Because this country has a habit
of making bad decisions
in the wake
of a national crisis.
(coughs):
Iraq War.
-(laughter)
-Hmm?
(coughs):
Patriot Act.
(clears throat)
(coughing):
Japanese internment camps.
Fuller House.
(laughter, applause)
Well...
Once the Olsen twins weren't in,
Wilmore was out.
Okay?
But look, here's the thing,
though, it's easy to say,
"Well, this person is dangerous,
they shouldn't be allowed
to buy guns,"
but it isn't that simple, okay?
Anyone can be under
the investigation of the FBI.
I mean, Martin Luther King was
under investigation of the FBI.
John Lennon was under
investigation of the FBI.
Hillary Clinton is currently
under investigation of the FBI.
Right? How embarrassing
would it be to have a president
who's on the no-fly list?
(laughter)
(as Hillary):
Could we do the summit
at the White House instead? Oh.
Air Force One is in the shop.
Yeah. All right.
And because it's the government,
you know,
there's also the problem
of bureaucratic error.
For instance-- this is true--
do you know who else
has been denied entry
to airplanes?
Air marshals who are supposed
to protect us while flying,
but who also have names too
similar to someone on the list.
Like, Dave ben Laden.
(laughter)
But B-E-N Laden. Mm-hmm.
He's not Laden now.
He's been Laden.
-(laughter)
-Thank you very much.
See how I did that?
With the "been."
-(applause)
-He ain't Laden no mo'.
-(whooping, whistling)
-Thank you! Thank you, lady!
That's what I'm talking about!
Whistle Lady, too.
Mm.
All right?
And Whistle Lady got it, too.
-Thank you, Whistle Lady.
-(laughter)
Okay. Here's my other problem
with this list
of "potential" bad people.
Any of us could wind up
on this thing--
and by "any of us," I mean
mostly black and brown people.
Do you know what putting
black people on a no-fly list
would mean
to Southwest Airlines?
(laughter)
-Decimated, all right?
-(laughter)
And by the way, neither
the San Bernardino shooters
nor the Orlando shooter
were on the no-fly list.
I'll tell you what, how
about if we put all Americans
on a no-buying-assault-weapons
list?
-(whooping, applause) -That's
what I think should be done.
How about that list?
All right. Okay.
So to learn more
about the process
by which these lists are made,
please welcome
the acting deputy undersecretary
of the Homeland Security's
Bureau of Regulation Management
and Lists, Dirk McDermond.
(cheering, applause)
Hi, Larry.
Okay, so, yo,
now, I have to say,
I have very serious concerns
about these lists--
so how exactly do they work?
(sighs): It's a very
complicated system, Larry.
-Mm-hmm. -It involves
covert surveillance,
-Right. -complex equations,
forensic analysis.
-It's...
-Really?
Man, I'm just messing with you,
man. If somebody looks guilty,
we just put 'em
on a list. Come on.
See? I knew it.
But... Look, you-you...
If you can just
slap someone on a list
and then take away
a Constitutional right,
you're depriving them
of due process,
which means any American
has the potential
to be on that list, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no,
of course not.
There is a long list of people
who will never
be put on a list, okay?
We call it the "no list" list.
We got this.
We got this covered.
But, look,
even the ACLU is concerned
that a lot of these lists
are just like profiling.
And you'll have a list
that's full of people
who look a certain way.
And by "certain way",
I mean people of color.
-Completely understand
your concern. -Thank you.
Look, that's why we have
a long list of safeguards
to prevent those things
from happening. We got...
-That's just another list.
-Yeah, all right.
How do you keep
all the lists straight?
I'll give you a hint:
it starts with an L
and it rhymes with "cyst".
-List.
-Boom, you got it.
All right, I'm still concerned.
Here's the other thing--
how can people
even get off this list?
-That's another problem.
-Oh, you see, Larry,
that's very simple.
You just have to get on
the "take me off the list" list.
-How do they do that? -Well,
right now you can't do it,
'cause currently there's
a bit of a waiting list.
But still, you know, you can...
Is there anything
someone can do?
Can they at least call?
No, we're actually unlisted.
Of course you are, right. Okay.
So, you don't think there's
anything wrong with this?
I mean, you're not even worried
about people's civil liberties.
As a black man,
I'm sure... I'm sure
I'm already probably,
like, on seven lists.
-(coughs) 13.
-What?
No, no, I... No, look,
listen, I got to run.
I'm sorry, I-I'm working, like,
over at Buzzfeed at night.
You know? I'm, uh,
working on some lists for them.
Yeah, like, right now
I got this one, you go,
-29 Reasons My Cat Can't Even.
So cool. -Okay, all right.
Whatever.
Dirk McDermond, everybody.
We'll be right back.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)